CHUCK SCHUMER IS A THROW
BACK TO THE DEMOCRATS
SEGREGATION ERA.
SADLY HE IS NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
THE LAST TWO NIGHTS WE HAVE
COVERED CHICAGO'S CITY KEY
I.D. CARD.
WHICH IS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO APPEAL TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IT WAS DESIGNED WITH THEM
WITH THEM IN MIND FOR THEM.
THE MAYOR OF THAT CITY RAHM
EMANUEL HAS SAID REPEATEDLY.
YET, THAT CARD WILL ALSO
SERVE AS VALID I.D. FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION WHICH, OF
COURSE, OPENS THE DOOR TO
ILLEGAL VOTING WHICH IS THE
POINTS.
THE CITY DOESN'T SEEM TO
CARE.
IN FACT, AS WE JUST SAID
THEY ARE ENCOURAGING IT
AUSTAN GOOLSBEE IS AN
ECONOMICS PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT AND A
FRIEND OF RAHM EMANUELS.
AUSTAN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A CHALLENGE
TO THE IDEA OF DEMOCRACY
WHICH IS THAT THE PEOPLE OF
THE COUNTRY, ITS CITIZENS
OUGHT TO RUN THE COUNTRY.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN INVITATION
TO FOREIGN INTERFERENCE IN
OUR ELECTIONS.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANY MISREADING IT.
I MEAN, THE CITY IS ISSUING
THIS TO ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THEY SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRING PROOF
OF CITIZENSHIP OBVIOUSLY TO
GET IT AND NOT REQUIRING
PROOF OF CITIZENSHIP.
THERE HAVE YOU IT CREATING
AGO PIPELINE TO ILLEGAL
VOTING, VOTING FRAUD.
>> THEY AREN'T, TUCKER, I'M
YOUR FRIEND.
>> Tucker: HOW?
>> WE HAVE HAD MANY DEBATES
ON IMMIGRATION HERE.
I THINK YOU ARE JUST
CONFUSED.
ALL AN I.D. DOES IS ALLOW TO
YOU VERIFY YOUR IDENTITY.
THAT YOU HAVE THE NAME THAT
YOU SAY YOU HAVE.
IT DOES NOT ENABLE YOU -- IT
DOES NOT MAKE YOU ELIGIBLE
TO BECOME A VOTER I HAD MORE
THAN THAN IF A NONCITIZEN IS
SERVING IN THE MILITARY,
THEY ARE ISSUED A MILITARY
I.D.
THAT IS A VALID FORM OF
GOVERNMENT ISSUED
IDENTIFICATION THAT IF THEY
WERE A CITIZEN THEY COULD
USE IT TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT OBJECT TO
THE MILITARY ISSUING A
MILITARY I.D.
>> Tucker: THIS ACTUALLY
ISN'T ABOUT -- HOLD ON, IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE MILITARY.
THERE AREN'T A TON OF
ILLEGALS SERVING IN THE
MILITARY EITHER JUST AS A
FACTUAL MATTER.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
IF I HAD THIS CARD AND I'M
HERE ILLEGALLY, I'M A
NONCITIZEN.
I'M HERE ILLEGALLY STILL NOT
A CITIZEN I TAKE IT TO
REGISTER TO VOTE IN
ILLINOIS.
WHAT STOPS ME FROM
REGISTERING TO VOTE.
OH ONLY SELF-REPORTING.
>> YOU HAVE TO SWEAR AN
OATH.
>> Tucker: OH YOU HAVE TO
SAY THAT YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
VOTE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ONLY
THING STOPPING PEOPLE FROM
VOTER FRAUD IS THEIR OWN
CONSCIENCE?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
TELL ME ANOTHER.
>> YOU COMMIT A FELONY.
IT'S THAT YOU COMMIT A
FELONY.
>> Tucker: SO IF I BELIEVE A
TRAY ON ROLEX WATCHES ON THE
SIDEWALK MY VIEW PEOPLE
CAN'T TAKE THEM THAT WOULD
BE A FELONY.
SHOULD I EXPECT NO ONE WOULD
TAKE ONE?
LET'S BE REAL.
>> NOTHING ABOUT ILLINOIS
DISTINCTIVE ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS THE CASE IN ALMOST
ALL THE STATES OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Tucker: OH THAT THEY
ISSUE GOVERNMENT I.D. CARDS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS?
>> REGISTER TO VOTE.
NO THAT WHEN YOU REGISTER TO
VOTE DO YOU NOT DOCUMENT
YOUR CITIZENSHIP.
YOU SWEAR AN OATH THAT YOU
ARE A CITIZEN.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
>> PRECINCT FOR 30 DAYS AND
NOT A FELON.
>> Tucker: ONLY TWO STATES
OUT OF 50 THAT REQUIRE PROOF
OF CITIZENSHIP.
BUT WE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
BEING LECTURED BY THE LEFT
ABOUT HOW FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IS
HOLLOWED OUT OUR DEMOCRACY.
I'M GIVING YOU A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE OF HOW THAT COULD
HAPPEN AND I BELIEVE IT IS
HAPPENING.
WHERE FOREIGN CITIZENS.
>> YOU ARE MAKING A MISTAKE.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WHY WOULDN'T WE VERIFY THE
CITIZENSHIP OF EVERY VOTER?
WHAT'S THE ANSWER TO THAT?
>> THE ANSWER TO THAT IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, PROBABLY
IN THE MILLIONS WHO DO NOT
HAVE THAT CIPTIOND OF
CITIZENSHIP.
ONLY A THIRD THE COUNTRY HAS
A PASSPORT.
SO YOU WOULD DISENFRANCHISE.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
SLOW DOWN.
YOU DON'T NEED A PASSPORT.
>> DOCUMENT THEIR
CITIZENSHIP.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WRONG.
A THIRD OF THE COUNTRY.
>> IT ISN'T WRONG.
>> Tucker: NO, NO.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE WRONG.
I DO THIS FOR A LIVING.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE WRONG.
>> 5% OF AMERICA HAS A
PASSPORT.
110 MILLION PASSPORTS.
>> Tucker: NOT ABOUT
PASSPORTS.
YOU CAN BRING A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ONE WE CAN
GET YOU ONE.
TAKE THE MONEY PAID ON CITY
CARD I.D. AND APPLIED IT TO
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
BIRTH CERTIFICATES AND GOT
THEM BIRTH CERTIFICATES.
>> THE CITY CARD I.D. IS A
SUBWAY CARD AND ALLOWS TO
CHECK OUT LIBRARY BOOKS.
IT DOES NOT GIVE YOU THE
RIGHT TO REGISTER TO VOTE IF
YOU ARE NOT A CITIZEN.
>> Tucker: YES, IT DOES.
>> IT DOES NOT.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, SLOW
DOWN.
>> IT ALLOWS YOU TO VERIFY
YOUR IDENTITY ONLY.
THAT'S ALL IT DOES.
AGAIN AND SPEAK SLOWLY
BECAUSE I MEAN, YOU ARE
ARGUING IN FAVOR OF VOTER
FRAUD.
AND YOUR PARTY.
>> I AM ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU ARE NOT CORRECT.
>> Tucker: YES, YOU ARE.
YES, YOU ARE.
>> A HOMELESS PERSON CANNOT
GET A DRIVERS LICENSE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANDREAS. ANDREAS
THEY DON'T HAVE ANDREAS. ANDREA.
THEY CAN GET ONE OF THESE
CITY RIGHT IDS.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY CAN USE THAT AND GO
DOWN AND VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY.
IF THEY ARE NOT A CITIZEN
THEY CAN'T REGISTER TO VOTE.
THAT IS.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE AREN'T
ALLOWED TO ROB LIQUOR STORES
BUT THEY DO.
THEY BROKE OUR LAW.
IF WE CARE ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ONLY
ALLOWED TO VOTE DO.
>> DON'T END IDS WHICH ARE
DESIGNED TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
CHECK OUT BOOKS FROM THE
LIBRARY TO RIDE ON THE
SUBWAY.
THEY CAN'T GET A DRIVERS
LICENSE.
>> Tucker: THAT IS NOT THE
POINT AND IT'S NOT THE TOPIC
UNDER DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT IS THE POINT.
THAT'S WHY THEY CRATED THESE
IDS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING THE IDS
ARE VALID FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION.
MY QUESTION IS WHY DON'T WE
SPEND AND I WILL CRICKET TO
IT, A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY,
VERIFYING THAT EVERYONE WHO
VOTES, IF WE CARE ABOUT THE
SANCTITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
WHICH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DOES NOT AND WE BOTH KNOW
THEY DON'T BUT PRETENDING WE
DO WHY DON'T WE MAKE SURE
THEY ARE CITIZENS VOTING?
WHY NOT TRY THAT.
>> I UNDERSTANDING THAT
ARGUMENT AND IT WOULD APPLY
TO 48 DIFFERENT STATES, NOT
JUST TO THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
>> Tucker: I AGREE,
COMPLETELY.
WHY AREN'T WE DOING THAT.
>> WE DO NOT HAVE A [BLANK]
COUNTY RULE OF THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR THAT
MILLIONS OF LEGITIMATE
CITIZENS WILL HAVE A ONEROUS
TIME.
IT WILL BE DIFFICULT.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T WE HELP
THEM?
WE JUST MADE A CITY CARD FOR
ILLEGALLIES, HELP OUR OWN
CITIZENS WHO DON'T HAVE
BIRTH CERTIFICATES.
I'M CONFUSED.
WHY DON'T WE MAKE THAT
EFFORT?
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT.
>> WE SHOULD.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT EVEN
TRYING BECAUSE --
>> -- WE SHOULD PROSECUTE.
>> Tucker: ILLEGALS TO VOTE.
>> PROSECUTE TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW ANYONE WHO
COMMITS A FELONY U.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T NEED TO
PROSECUTE ANYONE.
>> NOT BE USED TO MAKE YOU
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T MAKE YOU
ALLOWS TO YOU VOTE
INELIGIBLE WHICH IS WHY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
THOUGHT THIS DOWN TOMORROW.
>> IT'S AN IDENTIFICATION.
>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF
TIME.
I THINK SOME OF YOU KNOW